we talked about the Jenna Julie this
thanks the other things with you guys
this is these are official moves now
here's something to give people when
they come on up these are the official
guest gifts of the podcast from Ella and
in red and you know retro actively this
podcast is brought to you by canvas pop
bring wonderful moments to life in
beautiful color on beautiful materials
with canvas pop you basically send them
customizable images like you can send
your own image and then add dates and
stuff and whatever you want make it your
own image and they will blow it up on
this beautiful canvas for you and you
know that sounds like a great
Valentine's gift if I might if I might
add myself Oh 50 bucks off your order
with canvas pop when you like canvas pop
calm and typing in product code JJ love
Oh al my heart order by July 1st so
goodbye January 31st to get it by
Valentine's Day thank you thank you can
discuss yeah these are uh we got these
today they came in the mail today [ __ ]
dope ass yeah [ __ ] Dalton off I was
gonna say so uh we got these mugs with
our logo and we have stickers with our
logo and they both of the batches we
ordered of both of those things both of
the king batches we order our test
batches dude you didn't I already use
that joke my vlog anyway they're test
batches because we want to see how they
came out with the stickers in the mugs
but once our podcast website is up and
running which it's in the works right
now we're working on that once we have a
website that's up we will have a store
where you can buy this for you your
loved ones as well as the stickers so
yes we'll have a little bit of podcast
merch going on for you wonderful people
podcast fam podcast fan archives fearful
life
Paquette fam for a decade and forget you
know you know what I heard today what
when gee I uh
I watched someone and you can probably
know he isn't named Dame drops no big
black dude he eats food in his car
reviews yeah no I know oh yeah I met him
it was damn drops yeah that's his name
that's when I first met him and he's
very nice and I like really loved like
getting to talk to him super cool guy
and I followed him ever since big gun
I've been watching his videos which is
also really cool when you meet someone
and get fallen like that but so he does
fast food reviews in his car he's in
wonder he released a video today saying
that's it for me doing the fast food
reviews I need to take care of my health
I'll do other food reviews but I just
want you guys to know that fast food
movies are done and it was like a great
video because he well and he was also
like speaking from his heart you know
and one thing he said what reminded me
is when he was addressing the fact that
people will unsub and he's okay with
that but it is how we put it he said
some of you are here for a season and
some are you here for a reason
and I was like damn dude damn no pun
intended like that that it really rung a
bell with me because like when you have
people follow you everywhere they're hit
they're there for a reason not a season
and you guys are here for a reason you
know if we change our subjective you
know our podcasts change or his videos
are faster anymore you're there you for
the long you're there for a reason and
they're like really like hit me I like I
love the way he put that that's really
nice yeah really funny really nice guy
if you guys haven't seen him you should
check his stuff out yeah Tim yeah I
loved hanging out with him that night I
know he's really nice he might be a mark
I know he was making me laugh so [ __ ]
hard he's a funny dude nice anyway we
just came back from shoot some clouds
been kind of a cloud chaser lately we
looked at all clouds I got to hang out
Trevor Moran earlier today Jenna shot a
little collab with Trevor yeah if you're
watching we Brendan yeah we did it if
you're watching this I will be up on my
vlog channel and Trevor's channel I we
were gonna shoot like something I'd let
him to believe that we were gonna shoot
a collab and we just scared the [ __ ] out
of him yeah that was
your version of a club hahaha we did it
was so stupid you're doing terrible at
prank so it was fun I like to scare
people with their own music yeah yeah
I'm pretty spooked I think we are done
watches song anyone watch the footage
yet so we don't know what it looks like
but hopefully internet will be [ __ ]
great
it'll be [ __ ] it'll be [ __ ] yeah
little bit [ __ ] GG always Lee oh wow
we are in like turn-up mode right now no
well yeah for you guys it's Monday
sorry it's a week respectively yeah no
um anyway I had an idea that we talked
about or or share our injury stories
just all all yeah like just dedicate the
whole podcasts a funny or terrifying or
whatever stories about injuries that
we've had or experience in our life and
I think that could be interesting why
not let them do it um I mean we both
been athletes our whole life so we've
had our fair share
yeah we've seen our vision I feel like
I've seen something I've seen some of
the most gruesome [ __ ] mm-hmm no
thank you I don't want to relive those
experiences there's one that I didn't
see it personally but it happened in
okay no okay why don't you talk about
one that you do got [ __ ] run No okay
uh one that I had yeah well I've already
told the boat story people know that
I've already told how I broke my nose
and then I ran into the back of my mom's
car but I cancer
if you won't you start okay I did one
recently like Julianne watched me do it
it was a [ __ ] awful okay so we were
really drunk one night and we had gone
out to like a bar I think and we came
back to the house it was our old house
it's a Hollywood that name oh yeah we
came back to the house and we were uh
listening to music and dancing around we
like moved the furniture so we had like
a big dance floor and we were just
dancing with each other like having a
great little like Jenna Julianne time
and I decided that
it would be really dope I realized I did
this at Ryan's house too when I was like
really drunk because he sent me a
picture of me doing a headstand on a
chair and I was like the [ __ ] so if
you're trying to picture what this looks
like it's like a couch chair it's not
just like a [ __ ] dining yeah if you
guys have seen my videos with the like
squiggly line chair yeah the column
chevron chevron the shet the white and
navy blue Chevron chairs Dom they don't
really have it's like this chair like
the arms aren't separated from the chair
it's all sort of one piece and it's a
thicker chair it's a one-inch chair
noonish um so I had but I did that at
Ryan's house and he sent me a picture I
didn't remember doing it I'm like oh my
god I'm so embarrassing I don't know why
why Ryan's still friends with me at this
[ __ ] obviously he's done some dumb
[ __ ] in his house right and I feel like
he never does anything dumb he's just
Ryan all just right he just comes I'm
hearing right I know and then I just
ratchet the [ __ ] out I'm like why do you
even like me [ __ ] man
you can take the girl out of the rats
but you can take your actor thanks for
still being my friend Brad and being a
wonderful friend at them but so I
decided that it would be really fun and
like awesome while we were dancing to go
ahead and do a head stand on this
Chevron chair and I did it and of course
I my eyes closed
I'm upside down don't know what's going
on and my like I face the chair and did
the head stand onto it you know what I'm
saying she might the back of my head was
at the back of the chair
so yeah the back part of the chairs is
like kind of against your back right
yeah so I did it all
[ __ ] cuz I was drawn really great
ahead since like I can hold them for
forever no way are you talking no you're
your front was on the back side so like
oh I did it over the back over the back
so you were you're your front was like
like you remind the part where your back
does that makes more sense because I was
trying to do it okay cuz it yeah because
there's just no possible way that that's
gonna work out right it's not gonna end
well no matter what happens
and it didn't so I did it over the back
of the chair with my eyes closed
and there's still a makeup mark on that
chair and all of a sudden I just
remember coming crashing down like
forward like the way that I bent over
and did it but then fell didn't fall
over like over my back I felt like back
towards my feet because I landed on that
hard marble floor with both of my big
toes they just went slamming into the
[ __ ] marble and I'm like oh my god
Julian's like are you all right right
I'm like you have a lake magnet broke
both of my toes both of my big dogs at
the same time and you know we woke up
the next day five minutes later we're
just back to drinking she didn't even
care yeah yeah well cuz I know what a
broken bone feels like it hurts but
there but also you were drunk so yeah
there's also not a lot you can do for it
yeah so the next morning I was like oh
my [ __ ] like they were bruised I
couldn't bend them and I'm like what's
my choice right now go to the doctor and
[ __ ] you know have him told me that
they're broken not the stay off of them
no [ __ ] it so I'd say the worst was when
I was like lifting and stuff like
weights and everything and at that time
I was working with a trainer Jordan it
was like your [ __ ] deal right now
like I think I broke my toe from our
victim she's like are you you cool to
like lift the table get [ __ ] it's not
God um but they hurt for over six weeks
they hurt for almost two months which
means they were absolutely broken and I
still can't like bend them I can't bend
my big toes it's a nice battle scar it's
a nightmare
it hurts so bad they still don't feel
right yeah I'm like I wouldn't feel
right if I was that toe I'm [ __ ] all
okay we're gonna I still have them so
there's that yeah i drunkenly broke both
of my big toes at the same time without
a doubt they were broken that's pretty
good hurts so [ __ ] bad that's pretty
good I'm an idiot
I like that story because I was there
and we were having fun and then you
broke her big toes Oh
like who does that freaks only their big
toes I don't know but like I was like
you know and that happened I was like no
it's fine get up you know but then I saw
I was like you can even bend you're
telling me [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
and I started flemish up there [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] get this one here's um okay so I
went through this like really random
phase when I was a when I was growing up
where I like randomly like soccer for
like a little bit but I never we I never
know like not like when you're like 12
and you're on soccer teams and you're in
the league it's like when you know I was
like I was like late middle school early
high school just randomly like into like
kicking around the soccer ball I love
doing little tricks and whatever [ __ ]
like that I never played though and I
had a soccer ball and because I was
bored I just like would go outside and
do tricks I would do the thing we kick
it over your head and you know juggle it
kid get all that [ __ ] and I was like you
know let's see how long we [ __ ] it stand
on this thing you know let's give it a
shot let's stand on this on the soccer
ball like I got good balance this is
gonna end well
I stand on it and like not even a second
after I like like get my balance on it
one foot falls off and just pops like
crack like I didn't break my ankle but I
sprayed it horribly and I started
screaming I just like cuz all your body
weight comes down on that one ankle no
and I'm like [ __ ] screaming my mom
comes on she's like what the hell are
you doing standing on a soccer ball how
dare you we're gonna take care of moms
you would totally say that too like oh
are you hurt but what the fun way to do
it why in the [ __ ] would you do that so
yes I would I would follow this with I
never stood on the soccer ball again but
then I'd be lying because I have done it
so yeah yeah you know sometimes you just
gotta roll dice instead on soccer ball
are we [ __ ] I don't we [ __ ] yeah
Mandy I actually have a couple stories
that I wasn't me I like witnessed yeah
what yeah why is it you buzz I'm scared
cuz I don't know well one of them one of
them is pretty [ __ ] but the other one
is my brother and it's funny okay the
Russian tell you I have another one I
was in college I think I told the story
somewhere I don't know where but like
you know when you're taking chocolates
off all in college I think most you guys
it yeah I played all four years
throughout go there's like hardcore
softball Yas
ah you know when you take BP like
batting practice you neither do a
machine or like we were in batting cages
like the mesh ones forever but we were
doing what I just thought of a great
lens sorry but we were doing this you
know you can do soft toss when you're
like crouching next to the person and
then they have those things that you
stand behind short of Hellscream yeah
well if it's not Paul may not be
announcements the different sheet
whatever we didn't have one of those so
we were doing like just a front toss
basically two people in batting cages
with no fence no no offense front soft
toss yeah but it was it was just so that
we could warm up and it was at the very
very very end of the season we literally
had one game left the playoff sling
Wonderlab game laptop and we were just
doing it to like get some cuts in and
warm up yes and we were gonna go do
something different and I was tossing it
to my friend Ashley and she hit the
[ __ ] ball so hard at me like like I
can drive line drive straight cuz I'm
like what the [ __ ] like no one supposed
to be hitting at that hard it's just
gonna cut in she I don't think she meant
to you know I mean yeah yeah and I'm
just sort of like you know half Stig's I
was a picture just sort of like happy
not even just like tossing it to you so
that you can get some [ __ ] cuts in
you know I thought we're on the same
page here she [ __ ] nails it at my
body and you know how if you're a
pitcher and we were super duper close I
wasn't even throwing it from however I'm
like [ __ ] yeah oh I'm so close and if
you're a pitcher it's all you can do is
react sometimes when it comes out guys
look you can just go like this or you
know whatever
so I basically did that because I had
follow-through amaretti followed through
and she just like [ __ ] pegs it at me
so the best I can do is just throw my
hands up and try and get out of the way
and I didn't get out of the way and it's
like hit my rib so [ __ ] hard and
Ashley would just start dying laughing
immediately because it made the pups
hollow sound you've your arm you
ever heard in your life because I was
just trying to like get the [ __ ] out of
the wheel real quick cuz I couldn't
catch it there's no way that I could get
my glove hand to here yeah I was like
just like [ __ ] peace I it made the
most I sounded like a tree like a giant
tree-like but like her more hollow it
just sounded like the most sound like
baby peppers really just like a thug
like this empty thunk and it [ __ ]
cracked my rib and I went to the doctor
and it was [ __ ] cracked and broken
but there's nothing you can do for it
but that was one of the worst because
because there's nothing you can do for
it it hurts to sit up to sit to stand to
lay down to laugh see me with reefer
febrile
it's [ __ ] the most [ __ ] painful
thing ever that was terrible though I do
not want to break a rib ever again yeah
because all you can do is just chill and
like have it yeah I have horrible
memories of broken ribs horribly
memories like laughing is one of the
worst which is you can't sleep cause you
wake up just from breathing right ah
that seems like part of a broken rib and
people just try and make you laugh
perfect
[ __ ] you yeah the friends you got to
keep around [ __ ] you guys [ __ ] all y'all
oh yeah what else you got
tell me the one about Marlon I think
I've told you this before he our line is
Julian's brother about Marlow rather my
Loretto brother you guys know who he is
every time he's in a blog you're like
[ __ ] me Marlon yeah that's pretty in
love with my brother um daddy daddy
daddy Marlon is daddy
um no so he was very injury prone as a
kid he was just very fragile you all are
though aren't you uh I was not injury
prone no but you go through those little
phases well oh yeah I go through phases
and I get this from my mom where I'll
look I'll get one cut on my finger and
then I get ten cuts like it all and when
it rains it pours for that type of thing
that's not injurious Alex Phoenix yeah
no I get like burns cuts like little
things in the kitchen it's more like
kitchen stuff yeah but that's not
injuries they injuries my brother was
injured
I wasn't super injured pony I got hurt
everyone so Baba anyway he was he was
like the youngest kid in majors which is
literally there was minors and majors he
was like eight years old in majors
you're supposed to be like 11 and he was
uh he was the youngest in the entire
league and he was like so pumped up
about he's like you I'm on my brother's
team he's like three years old me
whatever yeah you just blew kisses
everyone poochy poochy oh and he was
like three feet tall so his strike zone
was this big so he got left months walks
of the season he got walked almost every
single time he ends up yeah um anyway so
one of the first games or one of the
games that he was you know playing and
warming up he was warming up on the
field with my buddy Scott Hyneman
you know who's with him the other
weekend he's now he's playing
professionally of course but mine was
plant warming up and for some reason I
factors through Marlins head where you
know warming up you're just playing
catch with a baseball you know there's a
line of people warming up and for some
reason he's throwing the ball he thinks
I'm gonna throw this one and then I'm
just gonna look away and then like zone
out like I don't even have the ball and
I'm zoning out if you're gonna zone out
you got the ball or you're done throwing
you know so he throws it to Scott and
then he looks away and Scott throws it
back cuz he you know he catches it and
you just kind of thrown not really look
and Scott throws it back and you know I
would say it came in about 40 50 miles
an hour probably
he wasn't looking everyone shouted his
name he turned boom right on the face
broke his nose shattered his nose and
there was blood everywhere freaking out
and then you know for the next couple
years
anytime we got in like a wrestling match
or an argument or whatever like brother
[ __ ] he be like how my nose my nose I'd
be like dude no way but I guess I guess
it really did [ __ ] him up cuz it was a
bad break now you know how I feel yeah I
mean he was probably milking it a bit
but no I totally understand cuz like I
broke my nose when I was eight I did a
backflip off of a dock and I hit my face
on the water
I don't even know that scar in that
story for you yeah well so it was such a
big issue for me because I continued to
do gymnastics and stuff which was scary
for you know someone that has broken
their face and then
when I got to high school I decided to
do diving which was terrifying because
all that is is doing flips like
essentially how I broke my face yeah
that's that's true so when I first did
it you know I told my coach I was like
I'm [ __ ] scared I'm scared to do
anything backwards I'll do all the
[ __ ] floor and facing dives and [ __ ]
I'm nervous
yeah and uh you know she was like one of
the best coaches I think I've ever had
she was like what's your problem daddy
you scared it being good or something
just [ __ ] do it
my okay all right [ __ ] I'm just like are
you [ __ ] good and you just face your
fear and get over it but you do you you
have like a certain fear about hitting
like I got hit by flipping the
unbreaking my nose it's an incredibly
fragile body part and once you already
break it I can't imagine like when we
did the yoga challenge and you fell on
my nose and it was bleep I fell in the
back of your head and it pushed your
nose into the ground at first I'm like I
don't think it's broken like it doesn't
feel like a broken nose but for so long
after that it like it didn't feel right
like you could clicking you look
clicking and I'm like I swear to [ __ ] if
you broke my nose
it's not like rookie it doesn't really
hurt that much anymore but it doesn't it
feels like very delicate yeah Kenny
doesn't feel like I you know I think
that's that's not my brother's like felt
for a while yeah I understand that no I
don't think it's like a baby thing I
think it's like sometimes your body
parts are [ __ ] up after you break them
go [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah get [ __ ] get far
in the face yeah um do you wanna do one
oh yeah I can't really think kind of
thing more um it's just you know it's
tough cause we're like we're talking
about injuries and they're like kind of
bad memories you know yeah but for the
good memories you can share them through
us your life with canvas Bob have them
blown up on a nice large beautiful
canvas of your broken bottom got the
good memories
oh you don't want you don't want to get
the bad memories on the canvas pop you
want the happy one so pictures of your
loved ones your animals that's all I can
think of maybe food if you really like a
certain dish get it get it Candice
popped the thing about canvas pop is
there's a lot of companies that'll blow
things up for you and make a bigger on
on some sort of photo paper whatever can
pop they have this incredibly
high-quality printing facility in Las
Vegas and they print these beautiful
like you have to see in person canvases
and they offer printing through Facebook
or Instagram although for the $50 off
that excludes Instagram orders you have
to do it separately to the website but
it's very incredible because we sent in
a couple pictures we actually did a
giveaway last time gems pop sponsored
when we had to you guys win giant
pictures of Jenna because we didn't have
anything to do it then we're going to
put them up but you see the quality it's
it's it's a picture on a canvas and
absolutely beautiful and the thing about
is like if you don't like it they will
100% guarantee a refund if you're not
happy which is great you know they're
not just going to send to you and and
that's it they're with you for the long
haul so definitely check it out at
canvas pop I mean it's a really awesome
idea for a gift
I think people you know yeah I can think
of a million things I could canvass pop
and give to my mom she would love yeah
you know that's canvas pop calm and
enter code JJ love at checkout he's 50
bucks off your order and if you want it
by Valentine's Day or by January 31st if
you don't then order it whenever the
hell you want
mm-hmm but use that code and now you get
50 bucks off so thank you Jeff ah thanks
canvas Bob
maybe we'll do more giveaways at them
because they were totally down about it
was awesome I was rad um I can think of
not a broken bone because I haven't
really broken too many bones like I had
fractured I stole things broken uh Mona
Mona
hmm Jordan knock on some [ __ ] work
I've always said that I don't care if I
don't know I can tell you about this
scar on my hand right here and how I got
that yeah so I went to Costa Rica well
he's talking to me to do that for what
oh yeah totally
but yeah a grown in know I went to Costa
Rica when I was in like seventh grade
with my Aunt Mary my Uncle Bob my cousin
Jonathan and my mom my brother and my
aunt Mary is like go go go go go like
she is I think in her seventies at this
point yeah but she is like legend her
energy is legend like we went on this
trip because of them like they invited
us to go with them because I don't think
we could have gone alone and they were
they had this whole thing planned out
like every day was like [ __ ] like let's
go go go look for a million tickets and
buy it they really wanted to go
whitewater rafting and of course me and
my brother were life totally down it's
gonna be rad look yet and my mom doesn't
know how to swim literally does not know
how to swim and going whitewater rafting
is just about the worst thing yeah so it
was I can't remember what it is I think
Devin machine a category 5 or 6 rapid oh
my god one of the high the highest one
means that like no one's successfully
done it without dying oh it was the step
below that one are you kidding me I'm
not it was kind of [ __ ] dangerous so
you sit like up on the outside of the
bow and an octa [ __ ] paddle through
the rapids so that you can keep going
so we're all doing it we're living we're
so excited and all of a sudden we hit
this hard rapid when you do that it's
easy to like freak out a little bit and
just sort of like oh my god it's
terrifying
so my [ __ ] mom did that and I can
remember who else was on the other side
of the boat but if half of your boat
gives up while you're whitewater rafting
you'll flip like you or you'll get
tossed off the boat yeah you spin around
why are you so we hit this like the
water is rushing against a wall and you
have to paddle through it or else you'll
get trapped in this wall yeah so me and
my uncle of course my mom ducks in the
boat freaks out because you can't swim
doesn't want to fall off and me and my
uncle get [ __ ] tossed and because the
water is rushing against a wall we just
get sucked under water
under water so it's I'm crying yeah it's
kind of scary so I was trying not to
panic I fell off the boat all I remember
is being under the water for a very long
time and because it's like sort of
swirling against this wall underwater
you can't tell up from down you don't
know yes yes you don't know what's
happening anyone who's wiped out surfing
knows what that feeling right and you
have a life vest on yeah yeah but if the
current is pulling you under no matter
it doesn't [ __ ] matter so I'm just
like you know in jeanna lala land being
tossed underwater Oz and I pop up and
our guide gives me the paddle I come up
but I have this nasty like disgusting
cut on my hand that later got all green
and back didn't [ __ ] cuz of all the
water there's bleep all kinds of things
that are wrong but my uncle was
underwater for like ever
it felt like forever but I think it was
like a minute we didn't know if he was
gonna [ __ ] pop up yeah and it was
terrifying he didn't get any cuts I was
dealing with a cut but like she'd at
least be talking and survived but yeah
don't take your mom whitewater rafting
if she can't swim because chances are
you're gonna get [ __ ] guys why did you
do that that's so dumb mom you [ __ ]
step paddle ah damn machine I mean I be
kind of scared though to in turn swim
I'd be like I'm getting in this boat
y'all are [ __ ] if I couldn't swim I'll
be terrified every day I woke up really
every day with your penis with your
penis um have I told the base kit
basketball story on the podcast yet
what's the basketball baseball story
okay so I uh I was watching one of my
brother's baseball games as a kid and me
and my friends are like bored stupid and
we were playing basketball like you know
there wasn't really the core was sort of
like hanging out like you know throwing
the ball around and the game ended the
baseball game ended so the you know the
teams were having snacks there with
their coach is talking so me and my
friend Tyler who caught in a horrible
[ __ ] we walked onto the field and we
grabbed a baseball bat we're like hey
like there's no baseballs but let's just
you know we have this basketball and we
have this baseball bat
let's just [ __ ] around you know probably
is the worst thing it could happen
we have told it and get off the field or
like a cop the basketball like whatever
who cares so we get out there and I'm
like we're you know we're just running
around I have a bat we're like so then
we had this idea I was like why don't
you pitch it why don't you pitch the
basketball to me and I'll try to hit it
with this bat you know like I'll [ __ ]
crush it to be hilarious like a giant
basketball going over the infield it
hurts your shoulders to do that so and
I'm like a kid I'm like you know 13 not
that strong so he throws it and it's not
like he bounces it hurry rules that he
[ __ ] throws it like [ __ ] line
drives it and I'm in the batter's box
so I'm like hell yeah do this is a
[ __ ] Moneyball so I swing right I
swing trying to just like you know swing
right through it like I would a baseball
and that's the last thing I remember
just seeing it and then that's that's it
but what happened was I swing my bat
makes contact with the basketball and
ricochets like twice as fast back
towards my face and I know the helmet on
this is this is playing after a game
like we're not even so the but the bat
bounces off the basketball it's a full
bouncy guy's ball bounces off and hits
me right in the eye like right on this
top like I socket and I blackout and I
wake up and notepad you are one of our
coaches was standing over me like what
the [ __ ] are you doing like it was
another one of those things were you
like in trouble for being an [ __ ]
what the hell are you [ __ ] guys doing
I had the biggest black eye
I had this giant like bump right here it
looked like it looks pretty bad man and
uh I felt like such a [ __ ] [ __ ] for
like three weeks
being that don't ever try to hit a
basketball with a baseball bat
especially when you're small we should I
do in college so we would try to hit med
balls like you're not the super level of
it yeah at least that's not like is
bouncy it's a basketball you know
yeah but like if you do it and you end
up hitting it hurts like your shoulders
right it's so bad no cuz like you hit it
and then it all of a sudden like goes to
your arms like strains these top
shoulder mostly what else would you do
as a cog
[ __ ] them all hmm have you ever slammed
your hand in a car door
yeah I did it the other day you did yeah
I slammed a finger it's like so painful
yeah it sucks
I haven't done it hard to where like you
know I did it hard when I was a kid and
I remember like it hurt him so much like
when I broke my nose it hit I hit my
face in the bone in a part where there
are no nerves so it actually didn't hurt
at all the first time that I broke it
but I remember when I [ __ ] slammed my
hand in a car door it was like one of
the most painful things as a kid like
that feeling
oh because I did it nasty too like we
had to go in a restaurant and get a cup
of ice for me I'm just like so not
having brutal you know like scars or
anything cool we were ice skating my dad
ran over my finger oh yeah I fell down
my hands went on the ice and he ran over
with his skate yeah some purpose to
Inger's like hey [ __ ] you know I felt so
fast I like I put my hands out no one
could stop it's not even a big scar it's
just like you see that the little liner
though okay so here's the gruesome one I
got to tell this no I gotta [ __ ] do we
have it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] raunchy
like it's good yo who got hurt it's not
good it's like really upsetting and it
was horrible when it happened but it's
like a good story you know um so in our
high school baseball huh who's this kid
okay fine
let's call him kid a because I just
don't feel like using his name and kid a
was on the baseball team during the year
that the track and field like area of
the track wasn't being used for track
and field so basically track and field
would share the field the baseball field
with baseball
so the outfield for like the early part
of practice was was was track and field
they would be using the outfield
for their event practice so dangerous so
shotput stuff like that there in the
outfield kind of and so we know this and
play your a knows this so he's you know
they're warming up but you always know
that when you're warming up at the
beginning practice keep an eye out
because they are there so one day the
team along with player a is warming up
and he's in the outfield you know some
people are on the on the one on the foul
line some people are on the outfield and
as he stretches further and further out
you know some new long toss which he
shouldn't be doing when they're there it
just so happens that disc is practice
was happening right then and a discus is
the thing that you you know it's an
Olympic track and field event where you
hold it looks like his daddy is [ __ ] I
don't even know how heavy but if you
know how heavy a discus is you can look
it out like what the weight of the
discus is and basically you spin around
and throw it and that's that that's how
heavy it is like the event is just to
throw it as far as you can so this guy
throws a discus player a gets yelled
like heads up so he heads up and the
discus hits him in the face like a
discus to the face it was a huge thing
like everyone heard about it it was a
horrible thing he had to get like
surgery on his face he was fine
afterwards you know he had like a big
scar but he made it like it like he
didn't get any serious I don't think any
you know real injuries that lasted I'm a
lifetime it was just like horrible like
cuz I did like if you think about that
it's just like hurts your brain to think
about that thank you
no thank you discus to the face no thank
you
so no all set I think that was the last
of like sharing the field with tracking
well yeah field yeah big liability for
your school we had some stupid fight
yeah dude and not even like a liability
but like every [ __ ] season we the
soccer team would play games on our
outfield and just tear up and then we
have no outfield and then it's like no
one gave a [ __ ] and now of course they
have like five different fields the
moment I leave really sucks but yeah
that was one of the worst injuries I
think I've been around for you know and
softball they teach you like
the pop-up faces it's like a like if you
pull it out it looks like a mushroom
base is on top and the new Jimmy Graham
and they teach you when you have cleats
to slide with your foot up a little bit
because it can get caught under the
pop-up base and if you do it hard enough
and your foot gets caught break your
foot know your knee cap pops off as your
shin bone comes out of your knee oh yeah
my name's Jenna I'm here all day I just
want to do a little science experiment
to I wanna hide in Oh uh-huh a hole
under second base no underwear the base
coat yeah this wasn't an injury but when
I was a kid my teeth for really far
apart and my gum like you know your gums
it actually like ground I don't know
what it's called but I like grown down
in between my teeth so when I was like
six I had to get cut off huh yeah yeah I
can't be like the weirdest shiver mm-hmm
yeah
no they cut it off that's gross hey
Jordan girls hey guys gross
I'll get the [ __ ] [ __ ] gross that's
why my teeth were far apart
nope mm-hmm yeah it's pretty ill mmm
yeah I think I think that's all the
stories I have trying to think I feel
like there are more but I can't really
when we were kids my brother's friend
dropped a giant rock on his table when
his whole nail came off hmm yeah yeah
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] that's pretty
[ __ ] gross I'm trying to think I
don't think I have any more I don't
think he'll we were cleaning up at your
old place there was like a there was a
trash bag with a little bit of broken
glass in it and I reached into it and I
sliced my finger right up I remember was
one of those little espresso guys we had
to go to the hospital
way to get stitched up at the ER right
mm-hmm yeah how's gross you've gone to
the hospital a bunch yeah yeah where was
that I knew
where that was I thought is not on your
pinky yeah I feel fingers I was pinky -
there it is
see that sky right there yeah yeah right
across the knuckle I remember that was
gnarly dude
yeah and they had to seem so much larger
and stuff is nasty I stitch it up who's
easy anywhere else it's funny like I get
pretty queasy about surgery stuff and
like blood when I'm thinking about it
but like if I see it and it's happening
I don't like panic no but like if I'm
just sitting here thinking about it I
get really grossed out I can't watch
surgery shows and stuff without getting
grossed out but I've had surgery yeah
like I had the surgery on this part of
my heart yeah I had I don't know if I've
ever told that story but like I used to
be a camp counselor and one summer I was
like out in the Sun like a lot yeah like
this bump just showed up on my face out
of nowhere like it was a big bump and it
was just sort of pinkish reddish color
and it wasn't getting bigger or smaller
like it just all of a sudden was there
and I was so confused and so I went to a
doctor he said oh it seems just like a
bump and I'm like what do we means just
mom yeah yeah it was just show up yeah
and what is it it's a good doctor oh
it's just a bump yeah so then I went to
like a surgeon that specializes in that
kind of stuff and look at dermatologists
I think she was but the surgery yeah
yeah and she said to me um because I was
like I'd like to get it removed because
it's really kind of invasive it's right
by my eye like it's just you know I
don't know what I don't know what it is
yeah yeah and she goes she's like it's
not anything serious this is purely
cosmetic and I was like 19 at the time I
think purely cosmetic and if you get it
done if we take it off there's gonna be
a scar there so would you do that rather
have a bump or a scar and I'm like a
scar like do not care yeah yeah I just
said I want you to take it off it's
making me feel [ __ ] weird
yeah so she was so rude to me she was so
mean to me and anytime you get something
removed from your skin they
automatically send it to a pathologist
so make sure that it's not dangerous she
I had a follow-up visit it was I was
awake while she did it and you know
after she cut it out
in she like you can you have your eyes
up and you're watching the whole thing
you know she's pulling a needle yes yeah
I in this problem on my skin is like
getting pulled and like not try to
follow up visit because I had to wear a
bandaid on my eye like Nelly for a long
time and I follow up as it with her and
she goes you know we got your results
back
and turns out it was like a form of
melanoma but it wasn't the cancer kind
whatever benign was benign there's been
an anomaly not like no but that it was a
form of skin cancer live had was clearly
cosmetic lady exactly so then as soon as
she said that she was so nice to me
everything is so one of it fall because
she didn't want me to be like listen
lady you told me there was no problem
with this doctors without matters yes
exactly
yeah so then I not only had to have
another surgery again I had to have
three total surgeries Jesus to get
because they would open up the the scar
and then make a bigger incision around
the ones around it I mean it healed okay
you can totally know that yeah you have
to look for it though yeah [ __ ] this
is Niang but then you know finally they
had gotten enough of it off so it was
from being outside and this I'm
convinced it was from being a camp
counselor and outside the Sun for entire
summers at a time Sun can [ __ ] you up
its [ __ ] you know so much Sun can [ __ ]
you and believe it or not it was the
actual Sun and not like tanning cuz
later in life I worked at a tanning
salon I didn't develop anything crazy
although I do need to get my moles
checked and stuff every once in a while
did you want started it check your mole
check your moles cuz I'm a moly person I
got the moles claw gum moly
I'm covered in moles they're cool though
look at them look at all my moles
most of them I've had since I was small
my but you do have a mama but ma guys
right your injury stories in the
comments so we can read and laugh at
them or maybe not laugh but if you take
yeah hopefully you guys enjoyed enjoyed
us talking about our injury stories I
feel like you know I feel like this I'll
brainstorm I'll sit around I'll come on
the podcast and then the moment we turn
off the camera okay damn it
[ __ ] bottom well now so you know
hopefully that doesn't happen but those
are injuries stories hopefully you guys
got a kick out of that and guacamole and
guacamole now we're gonna go eat some
guacamole Wow Dan Mahli no okay Molly
you guys want to have an awesome gift
for someone in your life go to canvas
pop and and have an experience with a
picture looking different than you've
ever seen it before the highest quality
you can get on the most beautiful
material as big as you'd like with
whatever letters numbers dates collages
that you they will let you customize the
hell out of it go to canvas pop calm
enter JJ love at checkout and order by
January 31st and you get $50 off and you
can get it by Valentine's Day so thank
you canvas pop and make sure to check
out a sponsor it uh it helps make the
podcast free for you so we'll see you
guys next week yeah talking about
something probably a lot less gruesome
trail one time I went waterskiing and
threw up hmm on the skis or yeah in the
latter well that's a good place to throw
up I always like farting in the water
you'd piss in the water too right yeah
I'm awake you're just like you're just
hanging on the lake and then you go
that's nice like what my dad used to
tell us you're just peeing though oh
yeah dude I love that totally came like
yeah dude I do it in pools - doing the
bathtub - you're doing right now do you
right now
we love you guys stay tuned for info on
this stuff we're working on it we're
going to try to get this stuff building
for you guys because the new you up I've
said if you wanted the other guys we'll
talk to you next week